which drink today you're drunk so most
smart people are no fun that's not what
I'm seeing is a lie-detector test
all right that didn't exactly help me
hi I'm John I'm a private investigator
today I have to deduce which one of
these lousy drunks is actually sober
wishing Jeff Jeff mm-hmm like that watch
Krrish where you from fish's Indian
right on where'd you go to high school
han was in Southeast soon really does a
lie-detector test
are you okay
lolz
are just low to singular did you go to
undergrad how much we're at Ball State
and Indianapolis yeah I got you how long
you been in California about two now
fears always LA anywhere else la la
mm-hmm what'd you drink today Oh Crystal
Light that's all need to hang cuz I
don't drink water so you don't drink
water I mean technically there's crisp
there's water in Crystal Lake so like
okay so you haven't had any alcohol
today no one's last time you had alcohol
where at okay mmm doing what I like just
a claw there's no laws on Sunday so dad
watching football
okay so kicking out watching for ya one
claw no and I would be disrespectful I
had cried three okay
yeah suddenly now I want to keep it to
the late game yeah then I can do what do
you do for a living I'm a video project
manager okay calling you worked here
right over a month so it just started
mm-hmm where'd you work before then
Fox boards okay cool what's your drink
of choice I mean I'm a beer guy so Coors
and then white claw just cuz it's like
in right now
yeah does it taste good yeah it's not
bad it's easy and if you get the lawn it
tastes like sprite so really so we're
like okay there's a sugary yeah oh okay
it's lighter than beer Coors Light which
is hard to do
so yeah the claw is lost remember that
when she first get drunk it was like a
senior Inc in high school
oh that mm-hmm I decided to test it out
cuz I was going to college so I was like
I should probably drink before I make a
fool of myself so I did there and made a
fool myself around my friends before
college I you know Ball State oh okay
sorry
mmm no we don't like those people find
those people here who sure yeah
so I hear that from Indian as well okay
how often you drink um if we're just
talking like just drinking like a couple
beers yeah when I were like four days a
week ones last time you went hard not
this weekend but last weekend okay your
do shots yeah what's your fair shot
favorite well what's your go-to yeah I
just took Keela mm-hmm
okay how old are you 26 what what you
reborn a 93 looks like April 1st I was
ready for that question okay cool I
think I'm good for now Jeff I am are you
drunk
I mean you're supposed to do that
ones last time you drink Sunday I was
drinking white wine with my friend at
her house where's her place Santa
Clarita so what happened after the wine
we made rice and veggies and watch the
documentary it was a really good
documentary about how the strongest
athletes in the world are vegetarian on
Netflix yeah oh gosh
what's your favorite thing to drink um
I've been cutting back actually so like
wine or tequila
I'm not cutting back I feel like I'm
lying but I'm telling the truth
did you go to undergrad mm-hmm where
University of Iowa in Iowa City yeah
when was that when'd you graduate at
2012 told you 13 no I'm proud of that 30
when was the first time you got drunk I
was like 18 go on New Year's didn't
understand that Jager was a bad choice
Jager yeah and you said white wine or if
you're feeling Randy electric you are
you dating anybody right now
oh come on we're ask me I am okay you
ever guard reckoner
I'm a Scorpio so I don't tell you much
about myself you can keep going because
I don't know what the hell that means
Scorpio what's your zodiac sign maybe
later I'm in the middle of a citation
what was your degree in from Iowa
Spanish studio arts and cinema soo yeah
video SPI nice jus speaks Spanish si
pero hace mucho tiempo what'd you say I
speak a little bit I think I actually
said it's it's been a long time well you
said tempo give me a little credit where
do you work I live and we're good I love
it
what you do edit videos okay all right
cool Nadia I think I'm done with you for
the time being so thank you and you can
go stand there okay I really should be
making everybody walk a line down here
will you come and join me please
whoa hi excuse me I know so what did you
drink today you're supposed to guess
whether I'm like drunk or not and that's
the question you're gonna start with I
had let me see oh we had like this Thai
tea that's in the canteen it's amazing
but I ran out out of one of those kegs
or something yeah it's like when those
like cake stands where you can like are
you okay might I haven't decided
what's your name Michelle where you from
LA what do you do for living here at
BuzzFeed I work in marketing do you
drink sometimes what do you drink when
you do drink usually I go for like a
Moscow Mule or I go for it is a good
drink right I mean is it a tradition I
have a job to do okay
Moscow Mule that's it
[Music]
Moscow mules yes I don't even know ones
last time he drank I think the last time
I drank was literally like this guy's
fault over here let me try a bunch of
like Seltzer spike Seltzer's and you
know I was pretty drunk was this for fun
or for a BuzzFeed video it was her a
buzzy video okay cuz it sounds lame as
hell let's have a white cloth
are you dating I am are you in a
relationship oh cool how long have you
been dating just a little bit over two
and a half years what's the best thing
about your partner I think the thing
that I love most is that he's super
smart but he's still knows how to have
fun
so most smart people are no fun that's
not what I'm saying I'm saying that P
she thought he's super smart we can
still get down uh all right thanks
Michelle I may need some more help later
but thanks for coming on down here
what's your name
Quinton Washington Quinton but everybody
calls me Q so feel free okay qu e and q
I know but Quinn's on to you I nto and I
am where you from
upstate New York Rochester okay you ever
been
no thank you nobody's nobody's ever
where do you live now Los Angeles South
early okay so how long have you been in
LA in the LA area just over two years
two years was actually on Halloween I'm
welcome Halloween okay cool ones last
time you drink check this out my
birthday was November 10 and I was super
late all weekend so I've been drinking
for my Friday Saturday Sunday okay so
when was your last drink Sunday Sunday
okay what time
well maybe it was like Monday like 4:00
a.m. I guess so today
today's Tuesday so son Sunday night this
up sir Sunday night into Monday you're
saying gotcha gotcha what do you like to
drink tequila shots uh I like Mexican
mules
I mean it's whatever like I'm not like a
huge drinker but tequila is my thing
a Mexican mule is like Oh or mojito you
hear me yeah that meant that maintain
you the game yeah well you know yeah I
got bad news for everybody I'm pretty
sure it's wrong Bacardi has mojito ads
in Artie's Rome cut that out but it's
good what's your favorite football team
professional Philadelphia you're drunk
Eagles I also love cake about you might
okay I think I'm good for now q thanks I
might call you back later
thank you sir appreciated all right this
is tough nobody's totally schnockered
which is too bad q would you join me
again sorry do you see Paper Mate there
Matt I do as well as to arts okay
can you keep your eyes on that sure
this is time to some other okay thanks
thanks all right let's try again we have
this very sober behavior on the back
wall
yes toned it down Bruce thank you
I thought I'd make a joke and cross my
eyes all right that didn't exactly help
me um I don't feel hot about this one
but I think Hugh is sober the person to
step forward
you're sober yeah that's too bad I may
have smelled alcohol on Michelle where
did I go wrong the one thing I was
looking for I think you did there is an
involuntary eye twitch it was in anyway
Nadia wins I guess
[Music]